kann ich auch wunderschön fische angeln
oh mein gott meine lieben freunde ich
habe eigentlich gefangenen fisch essen
bei der gar keinen fisch essen weil ich
meine lieben freunde herzlich willkommen
zurück zu einer weiteren folge minecraft
weg mit mir contractor guten tag
wunderschönes weiter draußen richtig
kalt ich schwitze wie sonstwas dadurch
sieht man das nicht so glücklich dem ich
nicht dass es super dass diese funktion
nicht gibt jedenfalls hatten einige
unter die letzte folge geschrieben ach
mensch luca elf minuten reicht das doch
viel zu langen für fact macht auf dem
schneller
deswegen hab ich gedacht ich mache jetzt
mal ein bisschen hier ein bisschen
flotter totti und lieber nicht zu viel
um die uns meist rom
deswegen schreibt man die kommentare mal
was ihr davon haltet mich will sagen
deswegen fangen wir schon direkt damit
im ersten feld zu gesendet wurde von nur
der damals konnte ich habe
herausgefunden dass wird man eben einen
kaktus zuckerrohr setzen kann
sonst kann man ja keine blog in dem
kaktus setzen das ist gut wenn man platz
sparen will wenn du das in dem video
benimmst bitte sag ich bin nur 115 lp
danke bitte ich nehme dich dran ist
super fakes treiben ich mach das mal
ganz kaputt
das ist nicht alles schon gewachsen
damit ihr seht dass das ganze
funktioniert zeige ich euch das ganze
noch mal ganz kurz wer hat mir ganz
normalen sand kann hier das hinsetzen
das so ich kann hier keinen block
nebensätzen in den kaktus da kann ich
nichts nehmen setzen ohne dass der
kaktus nicht kaputt geht
ich kann allerdings nebeneinander setzen
kakteen kann ich so nicht nebeneinander
sitzen die kann ich nur in dem abstand
setzen
allerdings kann ich hier zuckerrohr
darum umsetzen oder halt ganz normal
auch so und damit ihr seht dass das
ganze auch funktioniert wenn das werk
setze ich den gamer tipps bieten noch
3000 damit dass es ganz wechseln kann
wer das nicht weiß was ich mit game
roddick speed verändere wer kann sich
folgende ansehen die ich jetzt gerade
ein blende weil da habe ich gezeigt wie
minecraft 10.000 mal so schnell machen
könnt und mit diesem command wenn ich
jetzt hier wieder drei einfügen ist ganz
wieder normal schnell und die kanten
zeugs hier nicht beim wachsen zusehen
also ein richtig cooler weg von dir
danken
ich denke jetzt natürlich mein name ist
der black screen ja jetzt kommen wir zu
dem geräusch und zwar wurde das letzte
geräusch was ich in der letzten mai
kräftig folge erwähnt hatte wurde von
kultur macht
als erstes traten mehrmals nämlich du
hast mit einem löffel gegen ein glas
geschlagen das hat die bestimmte kultur
macht schon nach wenigen sekunden
erraten und das heutige geräusch ist das
hier also wenn euch einfällt was das ist
dann schreibt wird es in die kommentare
die wette werdet ihr in der nächsten
folge wird und jetzt viel spaß weiter
mit minecraft wächst jetzt fragen sich
einige wieder her ich hab auch cool
effect so soll ich dir dann hinsetzen
damit du die eventuell mal dran nehmen
kannst und crafter gmail.com das ist
meine mail an die jedoch einfach mit dem
betreff in minecraft ex oder fax oder
sogar cool effect da könnt ihr einfach
die sachen hin senden und dann nehme ich
die virtuellen im video drehen wenn die
kulissen zu den nächsten feld mache ich
mal ganz kurz die times at auf 15.000
damit ihr seht was das soll
und jetzt denkt ihr euch bestimmt warum
leuchtet dieses gemälde und warum
leuchtet dieser teppich ganz einfach der
christie hat mir nämlich geschrieben
oder die christine christoph waltz der
criterion hat mir geschrieben dass wenn
ich auf glos bei uns beispielsweise
komme ich nehme ich mal dieses habe ich
das nicht egal wenn ich das so machen
sieht man ja gar nix wenn ich allerdings
so sieht man was und wenn ich den
teppich darauf tue ist es vollkommen
egal welchen teppich darauf durch das
ist der einzige block bei dem also ich
weiß der einziges ich weiß nicht ob es
bei diesen blöcken auch noch so ist
weil den quatsch stufen ich mache das
nicht hast du das mal ganz kurz
bei den quads stufe ist aber nur teil zu
aber bei diesen teppich der beeinflusst
dass er gar nicht das heißt wenn ihr
leuchten teppich haben wollt könnt ihr
das ganze so machen und wir können das
gleiche auch mit einem gemälde machen
das kann man nicht an der wand machen
dass sie das obst genau das ist egal wie
groß das ist ich zeige euch das mal ganz
kurz so hier leuchtet das ganze mal wenn
ich ein gemälde draufpacken leuchtet es
immer noch weiter ist ganz cool wenn man
ein haus hat und einfach mal so ein
gemälde aufhängen oder wenn man seinen
leuchtenden roten teppich haben will bei
ihrer veranstaltung zur zeit sind ja
diese filmfestspielen cannes ist ganz
cool danke christen nun kommen zwei fix
für die ich hier schon kisten aufgebaut
habe war ich das ganze nicht hinsetzen
wollte zeige ich das erst mal ganz kurz
was ich dafür benötige und zwar setze
ich mal hier die treppe hinunter
irgendwie die treppe und hier dieser
ganzen anderen treppen die kann ich
jetzt hier einfach mal irgendwo
hinsetzen
so seht ihr schon da sind relativ viele
ich mach mal eben den tag damit das
ganze ein bisschen schöner aussieht
obwohl nicht bei dem feld lasse ich
sogar man nach dass sie gut macht auch
ganz cool aus eigentlich jedenfalls
schon ich habe ein feuerzeug
es ist ganz normal wenn ich holz anzünde
fängt es an zu brennen das heißt diese
treppe ist vielleicht nicht mehr da das
ist egal ob ich das davor setzte so dass
dahinter setzte oder ob ich das daneben
setzte die die bretten die treppen
verbrennen gleich allerdings bei diesen
treffen kann ich nicht mal die oben
anzünden also bei den akazien
holztreppen und schwarz eichenholz
treppen schwarz eichenholz dritten roman
gottes ist echten kracher name
jedenfalls ihr seht schon hier
verbrennen gerade die ganze sache so die
ist weg der hier geht ob man oben noch
an damit dass ein bisschen schneller
geht ihr seht also ich kann die überall
drumrum anzünden
allerdings wenn ich die hier drumherum
anziehen die abgesehen obendrauf geht's
nicht ich kann mich halt nur drum rum
anzünden die ich schon weg ganzen
anderen treppen sind allgemein schon weg
soll ich setze hier mal einfach so ein
paar andere treppen drumrum die halt
ganz normal verbrennen würden so und
zack und ihr seht schon das einzige weg
geht sind diese treppe das heißt diese
treppen wenn ihr einen holzzaun wenn ihr
euch ein haus aus holz bauen wollt was
allerdings nicht verbrannt werden soll
weil diese treppen dann wird es einfach
komplett aus schwarzen holztreppen weil
lassen die einzigen treffen die nicht
brennen danke an dicht saba
und ja das ist wirklich sein name in den
nächsten verdanke ich mich schon mal
beikommen denn wir das zugesendet hat er
nämlich eine menge effekt zugesandt hat
das in der nächsten folge werden
wahrscheinlich noch ein paar neue effekt
von tom daran kommen wir denn wirklich
so 10 facts hat das ist eine richtig
coole sache tom freue ich mich immer bei
solchen mails ich nehme mir erstmal die
sachen hier raus und zerstöre diese
kiste wir sehen hier wir haben hier ein
paar hunde ich mal ganz kurz die mir
gehören so du gehörst mir und du wirst
mir und jetzt kann ich ja ganz normal
meine leine kräften oder jetzt kann man
sich die kräfte oder muss man die finde
ich doch die kann sich auch kräften kann
ich die nehmen dann kann ich die mit mir
rum ziehen dass er ist auch wenn ich
jetzt zum beispiel hoch fliege jetzt
kriegt da falsch an das ist ein bisschen
packe kann ich den quasi mit ihnen das
gleiche gilt allerdings auch mit einer
angel
das heißt ich kenne diesen hund hier
nehmen guck mal kommt kommission die
kommt damit klar
damit ist die angel durchgerissen
jedenfalls ihr seht schon diese eine
runde ein bisschen schneller als andere
ich kann quasi komm mit ich kann quasi
ein hund auch angeln dass es ganz
einfach anstatt dass ich eine dings
nehme hat sich eine leine nehmen kann
ich auch einfach so eine angenehme den
und damit quasi mit ca
das lag zwar ist noch ein bisschen und
ich würde euch auch
eine empfehlen tatsache ist jedenfalls
dass es funktioniert also ich kann
diesen hund auch an der leyen an der
angel
mit mir rum oben führen und ich kann
auch mit einer angel was eigentlich der
sinn ist kann ich auch wunderschön
fische angeln
oh mein gott meine lieben freunde ich
habe eigentlich gefangenen fisch essen
bei der gar keinen fisch essen egal ich
bevorzuge trotzdem die leute dazu
nochmal glück gehabt
freundlich wird sagen das war's dann
auch jetzt wieder mit der heutigen folge
minecraft am dienstag sich am dienstag
genau am dienstag ich versuche jetzt
immer am dienstag hochzuladen ist kann
man manchmal am mittwoch und am
donnerstag an ich habe jetzt ein
bisschen derzeitig versucht das ganze
zeitlich zu schaffen
wenn es euch gefallen hat würde ich mich
definitiv über eine bewertung freuen
schaffen wir 3000 gleich dass wir auf
jeden fall super geil in der letzten
folge hatten wir auch schon richtig
viele geschafft
ansonsten dem effekt zu senden wollten
kräfte gmail.com und eventuell habt ihr
das geräusch in dieser folge gehört das
war irgendwo dieser folge war ein
geräusch schreibt sie in die kommentare
der zerredet wird in der nächsten folge
erinnern
und dann würde ich sagen ein
wunderschöner tag